at this point we've gone over how to
understand the market we did this by
creating a market segmentation and
identifying our most valuable customers
to focus on we learned how to position
our product to these customers and how
to differentiate what we're offering
from our competitors and we were able to
sum all of this up in our value
proposition statement these skills help
you to not only prepare your marketing
plan but more importantly understand
your users who are these users you want
to market your product to hopefully you
have this picture by now now we're going
to add to us we've learned and go over
what to do before you launch with
pre-launch we're going to explore what
it takes a preferred for your launch in
an efficient and productive way we're
hoping to provide you with the toolbox
bunch of things you have to learn and do
before you launch your products this
preparation will help you launch more
successfully and more effectively if you
have a good app and I'm sure you do
you might be able to create some buzz
around your launch so you want to make
sure you are all preferred to it in this
lesson we're gonna go through finalizing
your marketing plan this is gonna
include what we learned in the last
lesson understanding the customer along
with your marketing goals your tracking
and metrics setup and your distribution
plan then we're going to go through
preparing your materials that you're
going to need for launch so your landing
pages your App Store listing and your
beta testing groups so to be as
effective as possible with our plan
let's first start with setting your
marketing goals and answer the question
what is this that you're trying to
achieve